so it's official epic games is suing
both apple and google after they kicked
fortnite off both their app stores
epic says that apple is anti-competitive
and has too much control over how
consumers spend their money
apple on the other hand says that
they've done nothing wrong and they've
filed a restraining order against epic
it's a legal battle years in the making
and one that can fundamentally change
how we play video games
all right guys if you like kind of stuff
that we tackle here on donate me well
then you're gonna love our talk show
clouded
which airs over on twitch.tv slash the
score esports
every wednesday at 1 pm eastern it's
where me keith dan and colin discuss
some of the biggest stories from
streaming in esports
so make sure you follow the channel and
hit that notification button so you know
exactly
when we go live so last week on august
13th epic games introduced a new way to
make in-app purchases on the ios version
of fortnite and this was big because
up until now the only way to buy more v
bucks or
skins or hell even the battle pass
itself was to pay through apple's app
store
which is exactly how apple makes money
off that app store
see apple is all about control and one
of the ways they control the financial
side of things
is by taking a 30 cut of all apps sold
on the app store
and a 30 cut of all in-app purchases
from any app on the app store that lets
you buy [ __ ]
basically every time you buy an app or
buy something within an app
apple takes 30 percent no negotiations
so not only did epic introduce this new
way to pay as a way to get around giving
apple 30
but buying [ __ ] using epic's payment
method was
cheaper and it saved you money it's kind
of like giving a digital middle finger
to apple and as you can imagine
as soon as apple realized that epic was
trying to get around giving them that 30
percent cut
they freaked out and kicked fortnite off
the app store
and that alone was big enough to make
mainstream news
the billion dollar battle over one of
the most popular video games in the
world both apple
and google removing fortnite from their
respective app stores
epic ceo tim sweeney has been this is
kind of kind of a personal thing
for him he's been a huge advocate
against apple's mobile app store and now
he's mobilizing his company and the
biggest game they have fortnite
to try to make things fair for what he
says is all developers
around the world but here's the thing
from where i'm sitting getting
fortnite kicked off the app store is
exactly what epic wanted
because hours after they got kicked off
the app store epic games filed a 65-page
anti-trust lawsuit against
apple plus they launched an ad that rips
off apple's iconic 1984 ad
plus they launched a marketing campaign
that paints apple as this big
evil corporation
now while epic hasn't stated this
publicly the narrative online is that
epic basically baited apple into kicking
fortnite off the app store
so they had a very public excuse to file
the lawsuit
and kickstart this marketing campaign
and considering it takes
months to organize a lawsuit and a
marketing push of this size
it's safe to say that epic would have
planned this all out way ahead of time
after getting kicked off the app store
google also removed fortnite from its
play store
prompting epic games to file a lawsuit
against google as well
imagine taking on apple and google in
the same weekend
and while apple hasn't fired back
publicly they did file a temporary
restraining order against epic on monday
august 17th
that would ban all epic related products
and development tools from apple's app
store
quote it told epic that by august 28th
apple will cut off epic's access to all
development tools necessary to create
software
for apple's platforms including for the
unreal engine
epic offers to third-party developers
which apple has never claimed violated
any apple policy
end quote and what that basically means
is that any app or game developed using
unreal engine won't be allowed on
apple's app store
if you didn't know epic owns unreal
engine and everyone uses it to make
their games from the biggest
aaa studios to the smallest indies but
if apple won't let unreal made games on
the app store developers could just
switch to a different development tool
and then
epic would be in huge trouble okay so
that was the news
and before i get into epic's
manipulation and pr
tactics i gotta break down just what the
hell an antitrust lawsuit is
and why epic is targeting apple in the
first place
to put it simply antitrust laws were
developed back in the 80s to prevent
companies from taking advantage of
consumers
and to allow for fair competition
between companies and this is exactly
what epic is accusing apple of doing
with its app store
taking advantage of both the consumer
and the developer by essentially locking
out
all forms of competition here's a quote
from the lawsuit quote
fast forward to 2020 and apple has
become what it once railed against
the behemoth seeking to control markets
block competition and stifle innovation
apple is bigger more powerful more
entrenched and more pernicious than the
monopolists of yesteryear
at a market cap of nearly 2 trillion
apple's size and reach
far exceeds that of any technology
monopolist in history end quote
and this is the crucial part of the
lawsuit epic is trying to wrestle away
apple's control of the app store
market and make it so that their games
are available more places
therefore they can make more money in
epics eyes right now the app store is
the only way to sell your product on ios
devices
which according to epic means that apple
can make up whatever rules they want
and basically charge whatever they want
because they're the only player in town
it means that if you're a developer you
have to give apple that 30
if you want your app to live on the app
store and it means if you're a consumer
you're forced to pay whatever apple
charges because
well that's the only place the app is
available epic sees this as
anti-competitive anti-consumerist and
monopolistic which is now
why we have the lawsuit for context epic
isn't the only one
fighting apple over its alleged
anti-competitive policies
apple is currently dealing with a
government-led anti-trust investigation
in the eu
and it's battling a massive antitrust
class action lawsuit filed in the u.s
back in 2019. the supreme court is now
allowing consumers to move forward with
an anti-trust lawsuit against the tech
giant
over the sale of iphone apps the suit
maintains that apple
has unfairly monopolized the market to
set prices
apple charges a 30 commission fee to
developers whose apps are sold through
the apple store
apple app store iphone users must
exclusively
buy their software there now the court
did reject a plea from
apple to drop the suit now if you
believe what epic games ceo tim sweeney
is saying online
this lawsuit is a good thing it
potentially opens up more app-centric
platforms for developers to sell their
product on
and it potentially gives consumers more
options as to who they give their money
to
and if that's what ends up happening
that's great no problem what is a
problem is the way epic has positioned
this legal battle publicly
by manipulating its audience into
fighting it for them
let's be honest here as much as epic
wants more open
platforms it's not because they care
about you as a person they care about
the money that you spend on its products
namely fortnite opening up markets and
allowing for more places for apps to
live
also allows epic to potentially make a
[ __ ] ton more money
so by coming out with this ad that calls
apple oppressive and by calling on the
millions of young impressionable kids
who have no idea what the [ __ ] is going
on
besides the fact that their hobby is now
gone epic has positioned themselves as
the good guy here and clearly
epic's plan is working just search free
fortnite on twitter
and you'll find dozens and dozens of
people backing epic
and saying how it's a good thing that
they're trying to take down a greedy
corporation like apple
to which i say it's epic games they're
just another billion dollar company
they are absolutely no different from
apple when it comes to making money
they just want you to think that they
are epic is banking on the fact that
either a
its audience won't understand what it's
doing or b
won't give a [ __ ] as long as they get to
play fortnite and
sadly epic's right because the truth is
epic doesn't give a [ __ ] about you and
this marketing push is just a
corporation's attempt to get the public
on their side
and to position the outcome as a win for
the little guy instead of simply proving
in court how apple operates is bad for
you the consumer
epic has recruited fortnite fans into
fighting a digital marketing war against
another giant corporation
all in the name of money it's
manipulative morally bankrupt and we
should not be celebrating it
at all so if you want to think of this
as a positive from a consumer and
developer standpoint that's fine
and you know what it probably is a
positive but don't think for a second
epic cares about anything more than
lining its pockets
off the back of your fandom what
surprises me the most of this is this
unconscionable use of 1984
it's so like ironically dystopian to
like
to make to do this this the whole thing
is just so
oh my god from an editorial standpoint
this doesn't make sense either
because who in their right [ __ ] mind
thinks that anybody under the age of 14
is gonna understand what the apple 1984
advertisement is
these [ __ ] weren't even born
when it came out
it's just like i i don't even think they
know what like even the book
yeah exactly i mean it's a famous book
but it's not like you know
everyone like like kids know what it is
no exactly so i was just like
you're going over so many people's heads
here that you know
like i don't even know if this is gonna
land properly but whatever